hello to welcome to the co playing Eric
F who is that no name ok so I'm playing
a little bit of the English opening I
mentioned on the channel that there is a
project for chest 24 where I'm looking
at the English opening this project is
completed I'm happy about that oh that's
a transposition that I should have
played d3 first ok it's not a big deal
but given the choice up pretty much
would have liked to have the night on e
to ok and he's playing this very quickly
seems like it's something that he knows
kind of interesting yeah I tried to get
the night to you three support my piece
on d5 but also there is a possibility to
go before I wonder if he ok he tries to
go b5 himself yeah okay I'll go before
you seems a bit early but maybe it's ok
yeah that's okay don't see a big problem
there I want to open up the B file
anyway just a matter of timing yet this
project for chess 24 is completed they
are currently doing post-production I
recorded this at my home and it's not as
yeah so let's say the conditions for
recording those kind of things are just
better in a professional studio so they
need to do a little bit of best a little
bit of work there to make it look fine
ok interesting I think hmm Jack came so
now what about this I can take on c5 it
will take on c4 that looks strange I can
take on b5 rook takes a day 4 p-5 hmm
it's interesting not sure if it's good
though Kim not much choice now you can
take on before there's nothing
particularly wrong with that nothing at
all actually and now there is an okay
seems he's got hehehe equalised up yeah
I don't think I'm boost I think it's
equal
yeah boy quality you can just take
before just am absolutely nothing I
don't really see black i'm playing for
more though something I couldn't be
eight maybe with Bishop d2 I don't think
I can be worse in this position he's
taking quite a bit of time maybe it's
got some cool idea 95 okay this is
definitely something interesting so
what's the deal Bishop a 2 we enter trap
my rook Wow hmm okay
mm-hmm kind of stunt here I can't go but
should be two of everything else fails
if i take this Bishop a toucan I somehow
sacrificing the exchange I mean I would
I wouldn't mind to sacrifice for the
dark squared Bishop I can do this
actually Bishop a 20 pitch oh this is
this is definitely some nice
compensation on the long diagonal so
yeah something like we nee one I should
be three may be home I cannot take on c5
as suspicion hags that's a bit of a
shame 93 494 it with its fancy fancy
stuff okay this is definitely
compensation so let's play the simple
move it should be three maybe I didn't
really think about this so much mmm Q&A
6 Ruby 6 unfortunately hmm
Bishop h8 he's got just have six against
this does he have create a TN I know
that code and then I've got Quincy 1386
this is actually a very important point
Queen to h6 took me ages to see that it
would have been a pretty interesting
concept if I would have seen it before
hand yeah how does he how do you see
avoid getting killed now with Queen age
6 I don't really see how night d8 496
maybe but that also won't would work I
mean you can play that it shouldn't
shouldn't save him ninety-eight tweenage
696 bishop h three years curtains i
think let's say not be when i have time
you can think about it Bishop age 30 he
cannot cover g7 know yet fortunately I
did not plan this beforehand so i cannot
really take full credit for the concept
but i think after Bishop of six white is
in very good shape okay so he actually
found something against this idea hmm
that's not good
takes pawn takes I didn't see that
didn't see that coming time morning hmm
how to do this yeah i probably need this
no 95 I just can't believe it
look age 5 or something
unbelievable unbelievable what happens
happening here it was such a nice
position
just can't get rid of that bloody noid
check check white forfeits oh i forfeit
a long time what a bloody nonsense oh my
god yeah and what didn't I just check
meet the guy this must be checkmate here
after Queen age 6 as I just don't
believe it ok so let's have a look down
yeah that's a funny idea I just don't
believe it this must be very good
compensation you're on the long diagonal
okay Queenie one this is and Quincy one
is my is plus a million so why do I
don't I win this ok 93 seems to win but
that that also should win so I think
probably this is the thing I i just did
not realize he has screen on this heaven
this is winning her white yeah of course
it wins because 95 is such a big threat
and Knight g4 also 94 hmm I'm just
intending to go back yeah pretty much
that's much much stronger than my move
now it's still kind of kind of playing
so this is still winning but ok Knight
a5
I just don't I'm just completely out of
shape at the moment and it's not exactly
difficult threatens 97 threatens 96 and
if he takes it i'm just killing black
yeah that's impossible to hold okay i
have played this month and now he holds
on because that night only six is just
impossible to get rid of I mean I was
just yeah trying to somewhat continue
the game I had no time on the clock
download blundered the house and I have
no time to win with two seconds check I
came I don't like my opening the water
here I think I should start with this is
a bit better so that if if he goes 'if
I've that I have the additional idea of
going III 92 m white leaves i'm a little
bit more flexible him it's all a big
deals is a fairly general opening yeah
yeah I just don't have the sharpness at
the moment just not being able to to
play in those if you in positions where
I need to play force moves I simply
simply don't calculate when at all okay
well thanks for watching